is it as much fun as it seems when we
watch you on tv and you're sitting there
with colin jones
and you do that bit where you write each
other jokes
and you always write him jokes that are
completely racially insensitive it's
didn't write this one this is all me
last week was national rosa parks day
or as we call it in my house uppity bus
passenger today
there was a version of that joke i think
josh patton wrote it
and uh i was like but it was way
softer and i was like no it's got to be
uppity and they were like we can't say
he can't make him say uppity that's
gonna get him killed i was like yeah
that's how you do it you know
to me it's always like you got to turn
it way up but uh
that was colin's idea actually the joke
swap thing we have like darker harder
jokes that we like to do
but every time we do it we would ice the
audience the audience would be like
no like i remember a lady actually
saying no
in her chair as we're telling somebody's
jokes
and uh then one one time he was like
we should do this thing for christmas
where we just tell a dark joke and just
say hey this is
just a joke that got cut that we want to
tell and we gave that context
and every joke killed every joke that
bombed before
killed because they knew it was a dirty
joke they knew this was a bad joke like
we
were aware of it this wasn't our
commentary this was just a joke
and people loved it so colin was like we
should do this thing where we write
jokes for each other like
like you know bad jokes for each other
and make each other read it and i'm
thinking he's trying to set me up so i'm
like oh this guy's gonna try to get me
to say something bad
so i'm gonna flip it and make him say
some really really racist stuff
and i i we go in i go in with the
writers and we're going and we're like
trying to pick the worst possible jokes
i think that rosa parks jokes was in
there
and then i started reading his jokes and
they were all kind of mild
right and they're like why
wait a minute you just wanted to have
like fun
it wasn't a trap at all so i just took
it the wrong way
and i had him saying the worst thing his
head's in his hand and he's just like oh
god you're going to get me killed
it is brilliant uh it's fun too it's fun
to see him squirm because you know he
doesn't want to tell it
and uh he's got to get through it
because it's his idea so
it is it is fun to watch colin squirm i
will say that